[Music]
when i go to compete i'd realize there's
not a lot of people who look like me
there's an opportunity here to encourage
and teach people how to sail
my name is amy sinclair i'm a sailor and
i'm trying to open up sailing so that
it's a more diverse sport
[Music]
ready
all right everybody ready packing
i got into sailing four years ago
i had a moment where i was just really
unhappy and the idea that i was able to
come out every wednesday night and sail
with my teammates was like my one place
of like happiness and i loved that it
saved me when i was in a really dark
place
the team that i race with now is called
sweet caroline i love my teammates
they're my family
half the team is women we represent
eight different countries from morocco
to peru
jamaica
to colombia and india
but when i would go to compete i'd
realize we're the only team that looks
like us
one of the things that i wanted to do is
start a collective channel called
sailing noir an instagram account so
that i can get the word out about it and
encourage more people to join it wound
up taking off a lot of people started
following and reaching out asking how
they could learn i realized that there's
an opportunity here to encourage and
teach people how to sail so then i
started traveling
hi so my name is amy i am a competitive
sailor i would put together different
groups of people and we would go out and
we would sail for a couple days more
recently i went to kenya i put together
the first ever women's sailing team and
it was amazing first all-female
sailing team
competing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i decided we're going to start a women's
team we're going to join this race and
we're going to show these girls that
they can do this and help these girls
feel like they were empowered to learn
something new
it was probably one of the most amazing
things i've ever experienced in my life
there were all these women from this
community who never come out don't
participate in sailing or boating which
is two of the biggest drivers of the
economy on that island
we changed the way a whole community
thinks about women's role in society
[Music]
i think sailing should be more inclusive
and diverse because it's such a loss
that other people don't get to
experience the same thing that i do
they're just not used to seeing us so we
got to fix that
i would say try something new don't be
afraid you will surprise yourself when
you realize you can do it and that
feeling you can't put a price on that
[Music]
you